[Music]
hey guys
welcome to our installments of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing dudley dursley the dementors
and the opening sequence of the order of
the phoenix their world collided
it was the 2nd of august 1995 harry was
home for summer vacation
and was wandering around little whinging
eventually finding himself in a park
and magnolia crescent harry had a lot to
think about that year
and his thoughts brewed but not before
being distracted by the sound of dudley
dursley
and his gang beating up a ten-year-old
after a verbal altercation with dudley
and his friends
nudley and harry began walking home
together and it was at this point in
time they got into a
proper argument harry proceeds to pull
out his wand and all of a sudden
the world went dark cold and quiet
this sudden darkness and cold
environment was of course the result
of dementors dementors are dark
creatures that represent unhappiness and
despair
they are commonly known as the gods of
azkaban prison responsible for ensuring
that all of the darkest witches and
wizards inside
do not escape however on occasion they
have been known to congregate in other
areas
and on this occasion they'd clearly been
sent to little whinging
the following excerpt from the prisoner
of azkaban describes harry's first
experience with a dementor
an intense cold swept over them all
harry felt his own breath catch in his
chest
the cold went deeper than his skin it
was inside his chest
it was inside his very heart harry's
eyes rolled up into his head
he couldn't see he was drowning in cold
there was a rushing in his ears as
though of water
he was being dragged downward roaring
growing louder
and then from far away he heard
screaming
terrible terrified pleading screams he
wanted to help whoever it was
he tried to move his arms but couldn't a
thick white fog was swirling around him
inside him and all of a sudden harry and
dudley were faced with these awful
creatures
and in the unlikeliest of environments
caught completely off guard
the boys were viciously attacked the
following excerpt from the book
describes dudley's condition after the
attack dudley seemed incapable of saying
he shut it again and shook his large
blonde head and despite the sense of
numb dread that had settled on harry
since the arrival of the first owl
he felt a certain curiosity dementors
caused a person to release the worst
moments of their life
what would spoiled pampered bullying
dudley have been forced to hear
and what i always found interesting
about this passage is that while the
book itself poses the question
what would dudley have seen it's never
actually answered
so what did the spoiled pampered
bullying
dudley see in a 2004 interview rolling
was asked this very question
and replied with a rather ambiguous ah
good question
you'll find out but of course we didn't
find out as this was never further
addressed in the books
perhaps it was her intention but we
never got to it however
fortunately for us rowling was asked
this question yet again
much further down the road in 2007 and
she said the following
people usually ask me what is it that
dudley saw during the dementor attack
my feeling is that he saw himself
exactly for what he was
and for a boy that spoiled it would be
terrifying so he was jolted out of it
dementor attacks aren't usually good for
people but this one was
this is an interesting answer and not
quite what i expected
but it does make sense after dudley was
attacked by the dementors
he was left in quite a state but after
some time had passed
he did seem to settle down a bit from
that point onward he wasn't quite so
awful to harry
and perhaps his little run-in with the
dementors gave him an opportunity to
realize the type of person he had become
that he had been raised to be dudley
didn't have to be terrible
he just started off a bit terrible and
it was perpetuated by his awful parents
as terrifying as being attacked by
dementor is it certainly did deadly some
good
and that's it for this video what did
you think dudley saw
if you enjoyed the content please like
the video and subscribe to the channel
until next time you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you